the writers behind Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker have got some explaining to do
Skywalker writer director JJ Abrams was
recently captured on video explaining to
a group of fans the oddly less than
defined relationship between Rey and
kylo Ren and Star Wars sequel films ever
since the release of Star Wars The Force
awakens there has been a significant
subset of fans call them the reloj
contingent who have been pining to see
the resistance fighter Rey and the first
order villain kylo just admit their
feelings for each other already there
has always been a strong chemistry
between the two which could easily be
taken for a romantic undertone to their
relationship despite the fact that for
most of the sequel trilogy the two were
playing for opposite teams during the
events of the rise of Skywalker Ren is
moved to discard his old lightsaber and
reclaim his original identity has been
solo son of Han and Leia and the former
pupil of Luke Skywalker
after Rey is seemingly killed during her
fight with Emperor Palpatine then
redeems himself by transferring his life
force to her saving her life before he
becomes one with the force
he kisses her seemingly vindicating
every fan who ever insisted there was
something going on between those two you
come from nothing you're nothing
from alchemy according to Abrams though
that something wasn't what we might have
thought it was is off-the-cuff
explanation of the relationship to a
group of fans was posted online by
Twitter user rise of kylo and it may
make you cringe just a little in the
video they posted Abram said there's as
much of a brother-sister thing between
kylo and Rey as there is a romantic
thing it's more like they're just bound
together in this crazy spiritual way
Abrams bolstered his argument by looking
to musical maestro john williams who
composed the music for Star Wars from
the very beginning before things got so
complicated between its main characters
but they'll make her sad if you listen
to John Williams when he first wrote the
Luke theme it was a romantic theme for
Luke and Leia that was kind of what he
was thinking because he didn't know
where it was going what some might find
most interesting about Abrams remarks is
how they counter a common criticism of
the Star Wars sequel trilogy
you'll recall that Abrams directed the
force awakens then hand it off the last
Jedi to writer director Rian Johnson
Abrams was then recruited to finish off
the trilogy after the director who was
originally attached to Episode nine
Colin Trevorrow departed due to creative
differences it's also been noted that
many of the controversial narrative
choices made by Johnson in the last Jedi
were kind of undone by Abrams with the
rise of Skywalker like the issue of
Rey's parentage
for example while some reports insist
otherwise it's commonly understood the
Disney began work on the Star Wars
sequel trilogy with not much of an
overarching plan for how the narrative
would go instead the producers appear to
have just been kind of winging it
hoping that each new filmmaker would
seamlessly pick up from where the last
left off many fans have critiqued this
way of doing things but in explaining
ray and RINs relationship Abrams brings
up an interesting point the original
Star Wars trilogy those films most
beloved by the fandom also didn't have
any kind of grand design in place from
the start while series creator George
Lucas later insinuated that he always
had a sweeping plan in place for the
saga it's a matter of fact that many of
the original trilogy's key plot elements
such as Darth Vader being Luke's father
and Luke and Leia being brother and sis
lnto place pretty late in the game this
is why the Empire Strikes Back widely
considered to be the best movie in the
franchise and one of the greatest movies
of all time deign to give us the sight
of Luke and Leia whom we would learn in
the next movie were not only brother and
sister but twins engaged in a passionate
smooch my there all of which is to say
look fans we can all gripe about the
sequels merit of not being consistent
but let's apply a little consistency
ourselves the new flicks may have been a
bit confused about Ray and Ren's
relationship but at least they never
forced us to watch twin siblings making
out check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]